produce the support from Roche and Lille
colorectal cancer kills around 700,000
people every year that makes it the
fourth most deadly cancer on the planet
but it affects some parts the world more
than others if we look at the
distribution of colorectal cancer a
clear pattern emerges and it's the most
economically developed countries for to
hit the hardest European countries for
example have long enjoyed a higher
standard of living than most but they're
burdened with the highest rates of
colorectal cancer in stark contrast the
lowest rates are found in relatively
poor regions of West Africa the trends
can be explained by changes in lifestyle
for example let's look at the world's
most populous country China China's
economy has boomed in recent decades and
in turn colorectal cancer incidence has
soared in a population level greater
wealth means bigger appetites wealthier
people tend to eat more meat and
processed foods smoke more and drink
more alcohol the greatest changes in
colorectal cancer rates can be seen in
places with a fastest economic growth
such as Shanghai as populations move
from rural to urban settings people
start to exercise less as manual work
makes way for office jobs and cars
become preferred mode of transport all
of these factors what you eat how much
you exercise smoke or drink have a big
impact on your colorectal cancer risk
and they all go hand in hand with
economic development most people in the
world live in countries which are still
developing and so the global burden of
this disease is destined to continue
rising as economies grow even more
worryingly in most cases rates will
increase faster than over burned and
health systems can cope with and is only
going to get worse but it's not all bad
news and countries can fight back in the
USA the largest economy in the world
colorectal cancer incidence has actually
been falling in recent decades
the exact causes are unclear but Public
Health Initiatives and awareness raising
campaigns are fought tooth played a
major role it remains to be seen however
whether campaigns like these will be
enough to combat the predicted explosion
of this disease in many countries in the
years ahead